hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe I'm your host Sean
Carroll today we're doing the Q&A video
for idea number 12 which was scale where
we talked about the size of things I'd
hoped to get a lot farther because the
size of things is a big topic ironically
enough but the questions they were
actually very good so I'm not gonna try
to extend what I did in the video I'm
just gonna go through the questions some
of them were things that I should have
thought of to answer others were once I
wanted to get to but didn't quite have
time so the first one is what I
definitely should have thought of to
answer it's a classic question we talked
a lot in the last video about the
Compton wavelength of a particle and the
question is simply what is the
difference between the Compton
wavelength and the Deroy wavelength
which we talked about earlier so the
debroglie wavelength came about early in
the days actually it might have been
around the same time when the Compton
wavelength or the diploid wavelength
came about but both of them were before
quantum mechanics had been completely
formulated in its final form so a bunch
of concepts come in and only later on do
we figure out what they're good for
so the diploid wavelength lambda lambda
D boy there you go the equation for it
is just H I'm going to put Planck's
constant in here over the momentum of
the particle or in the nonrelativistic
reading what we don't need to worry
about special relativity etc it's H over
the mass times the velocity and the
point of this was roughly speaking
debris was saying it wasn't the
wavelength that was important what
matter was he was saying it matter has
wave-like properties this was the first
explicit statement of that idea
remember you had the Bohr atom where you
had quantized energy levels and the
orbits of electrons around nuclei but
the idea that the reason why the orbits
were quantized this is because the
electrons are fundamentally wave-like
had not yet appeared and here is de boy
saying exactly that and this is the
wavelength corresponding to a particle
with a certain momentum okay compare
that to the wavelength of a photon
before we get to the Compton wavelength
this is what came out of plunks original
idea in 1905 he said
that we all know that photons have
wavelengths we know they work sorry we
know there were photons back in the year
1900 we knew there was light
we knew that light had a wavelength and
what plunk did was to say that the light
is coming or at least is emitted in
these quanta of energy than it was
Einstein who said that the reason why
light was emitted in quanta of energy is
because light is in some sense quanta of
energy what we would say now is that
light is the vibrations in the quantum
electromagnetic field and when you
observe it when you measure it when it
interacts with something in D coheres
you measure it in discrete chunks of
energy and so what plunk would have said
anyway wrapping all that up into a
formula for the wavelength versus the
momentum plunk would have said that it's
just H divided by P I don't know why I'm
thinking so hard about this it's exactly
the same formula as the deployed
wavelength is it this is the point let's
call this the plunk no I can't cause the
pause a flame can I that's something
else let's call the photon Lambda gamma
okay gamma being the photon lambda being
the wavelength this was how debris got
his formula we had known from plunk that
an individual particle could be
associated with a certain amount of
energy and momentum an individual
particle of light which we now call the
photon and this was the relationship
between the wavelength of the classical
electromagnetic wave and a little
individual particle that has an energy
and a momentum okay finally you can
compare that to the Compton wavelength
which we introduced in the scale video
lambda Compton and this is H over m the
mass of the particle okay so we can see
something from these equations just from
the mathematical form of them a
relationship between these different
notions of the idea of a wavelength the
photon wavelength is the wavelength of a
particle with zero mass a photon moving
at the speed of light we express it in
terms of the momentum the way that
Planck would have written it was H over
e the energy but the energy is equal to
momentum for a particle moving at the
speed of light okay so when de rooy
wanted to invent a formula for the
wavelength of a matter particle he just
you
is the same formula that palanca given
for the photon but he used the momentum
okay and then we see from comparing the
debris wank way to the Compton
wavelength that the de Blois wavelength
is just the Compton wavelength divided
by the velocity and even though I'm
putting in Planck's constant here I'm
still setting C equals one the speed of
light equals one so this is always
greater than the Compton wavelength okay
the Devoy wavelength is always greater
than the Compton wavelength fine but
what are they like what do they
physically mean okay well I think of the
secret here is I've never quite seen
this written down or expressed in this
way so maybe some experts on the history
of quantum mechanics will correct me but
in my mind the point of the Compton
wavelength is not the wavelength it's
not a wavelength of anything in some
sense the Compton wavelength is a scale
it's a distance it's the distance at
which given quantum mechanics and
relativity it's the smallest scale at
which you can sensibly talk about a
single particle at a time it's sort of
the intrinsic size of the particle
although there's a footnote there we'll
get to later lambdas see the Compton
wavelength is the smallest scale for a
particle and it's not necessarily the
scale which quantum mechanics kicks in
it's the scale at which quantum
mechanics cannot help but kick in that's
the point the debris wavelength is the
actual quantum scale quantum wavelength
of the particle it really is a
wavelength so there was an experiment
done by Davisson and Germer in around
1920 that I write down no I didn't in
the 1920s they did an experiment where
they actually showed a thing in 1927
where they actually did the interference
experiment you know we talked about the
double slit experiment the double slit
experiment is usually given as a way of
thinking about measurement and what it
means an interference of what it means
but it was Davisson and Germer who
actually showed that if you have an
electron or a set of electrons they will
interfere with each other just like
waves do and
that interference pattern you can figure
out what the wavelength is and it's the
debroglie wavelength it's the actual
wavelength of the wave function
oscillating up and down for that
particle so of course it makes sense the
Debye wavelength must be larger than the
comp and wavelength because the Compton
wavelength is just the size smaller than
which quantumness takes over in fact you
can't even say it's just a single
particle anymore if you squeeze down the
uncertainty in the position of the wave
in the quantum fields - less than the
Compton wavelength you're not even
talking about a single particle anymore
whereas when you're larger than the
Compton wavelength when your wave has a
wavelength larger than that then number
one you can talk about a single particle
and number two you can do the experiment
to have them interfere and that's an
actual honest-to-goodness wavelength
you're talking about there so they mean
different things the Compton wavelength
is really you know it's it's kind of a
more fundamental thing as you can see
the Compton wavelength just depends on
the mass of the particle since we're
setting h equal to 1 you could equally
well write this as 1 over m depending on
where you want to put the two PI's the
smaller the massed larger the Compton
wavelength larger the mass the smaller
the Compton wavelength this is where you
cannot help but pay attention to quantum
mechanics but the point being even for a
very very massive particle where the
Compton wavelength is very small and
therefore you can imagine a state in
which the wavelength was confined to
that region you can also imagine states
in which the particles all spread out
and that would be when the diploid
wavelength is very large so I hope that
helps a little bit
here's a related question our particles
are elementary particles if you like
really point like hmm this is a tough
question actually so sometimes you hear
people talk about you know the proton
which is made of quarks and gluons is
not a point-like particle right because
it's made of other things rattling
around in there whereas the electron is
a point-like particle that is what you
will hear but we just talked about all
these different wavelengths that it has
you know that there's a Compton
wavelength below which it's
intrinsically quantum is there any sense
at all in which a particle is point-like
at all I think you know
that the short answer is no my favorite
short answer is no because the world's
not made of particles the world's made
of quantum fields as far as we know and
those quantum fields are vibrating
nothing point-like about them they have
an extent and even if they were
particles even if the quantum theory of
the world was obtained by starting with
particles and quantizing them it would
still be a quantum theory would still be
a wavefunction okay there's nothing
point-like about it when people say that
the electron seems to be point like what
they mean is as far as we can tell
there's no sub structure to the electron
the electron is not made of other things
of course it could be we don't think it
is honestly most of us don't but it
could be made of other things but
there's no evidence that it is so point
like is just a shorthand for saying not
made of smaller things it does not mean
you can actually shrink the wave
function of the electron down to a point
you can't really sensibly shrink it down
swallow in the common wavelength I mean
you could but then it wouldn't be
electronic okay next question this is
and this is sort of I'm cheating by
allowing a question that was more
appropriate for a previous video but
that's okay it relates to these
questions if you say that
the energy of photon is H Planck's
constant times the frequency okay which
we do we just did where where is the
amplitude in that formula why doesn't
the amplitude of the wave matter why is
it just the frequency that matters okay
and this is of course a very important
question I could have talked about it
earlier but I mean maybe I did allude to
it but this is where quantum mechanics
comes in so the status of the question
the context of the question is we're
saying that there are waves we're saying
that you know photons are coming from
waves in the electromagnetic field but
they have certain particle-like
properties and this equation here the
answer to this question is this equation
is for one photon a single photon
corresponding to a wavelength of light
or frequency of light given by F has an
energy given by this formula that's what
this formula means the point is if you
change
the amplitude what that changes is the
number of photons the amplitude of the
wave and this is very roughly speaking
because again we're really dealing with
quantum mechanical wave functions not
classical waves but roughly speaking the
amplitude corresponds to the number of
photons and we can even think since
we've already done our quantum field
theory introduction we understand that a
little more sophisticated level the
electromagnetic wave bouncing up and
down is kind of like a simple harmonic
oscillator okay so it will always be
bouncing up and down a little bit
there's always some tail the wave
function of the wave always has some
support at very very large amplitudes
but for one particle States for the
minimum excitation of that simple
harmonic oscillator the typical
oscillation the typical amplitude is not
very large as you excite the field more
and more as you introduce more and more
particles the typical amplitude of
oscillation goes up that's where the
amplitude comes in and this is you know
historically this is a crucially
important insight there's something
called the photoelectric effect and this
is actually the explanation for which
this is what Einstein wrote about in
1905 where he essentially introduced the
idea of the photon even though he didn't
call it that yet and this is the paper
that he won the Nobel Prize for despite
also completing special relativity in
1905 so the point was this you can
there's a certain kind of metal that you
can shine light on and occasionally the
metal will kick off an electron an
electron will leave the metal because
you're shining light on it you're just
shaking loose an electron not surprising
the question is when does the electron
when do the electrons get shaken free so
you might think that what matters is the
intensity of the light right the
brightness of the light the more light
you're shining on it the more electrons
get shaken free but that is not what is
observed if you do a very very faint
amount of light you might be able to
shake an electron free what matters is
not the intensity but the color of the
light the frequency of the wave right
the wavelength if you go to blue or
violet or ultraviolet those have the
ability to shake loose
Tron's and that's true even when it's
very faint as well as when it's very
very bright whereas very red light or
infrared light will not shake loose
electrons no matter how bright it is
okay and so this was the idea in fact
before quantum mechanics came along
people had exactly this idea the more
bright a beam of light is the more
energy it has the easier it should have
the ability to shake electrons free but
when you think of that light instead of
as waves as individual particles hitting
the the metal being observed by the
metal if you like then this formula
kicks in so a bright beam of red light
is a huge number of photons but that are
very very individually very very low
energy
none of those photons has enough energy
to break loose an electron whereas a
beam of blue light I don't actually know
what the actual colors or wavelengths
are but a higher shorter wavelength of
beam of light let's put it that way it
can be very faint but those photons
individually pack a lot of energy so it
just being very faint just means there
aren't a lot of photons so you won't
shock lose a lot of electrons but even a
very faint beam of blue light can break
loose a couple of electrons that's the
difference the wavelength
tells you the energy of the individual
photons the amplitude tells you how many
photons there are so they both go into
telling you how energetic that beam of
light really is okay
here's a related question on our little
plot okay you know we had the plot of
energies and we went from 10 to the
minus 3 or 10 minus 6 electron volts up
to the Planck scale 10 to 27 electron
volts okay so one question was where are
photons on that well there's a good
reason why photons were not there
because we were actually not plotting
the energy of particles we were plotting
the mass of particles we were using the
fact that mass and energy are the same
same units when you set C equal to 1 so
a photon which is low-frequency long
wavelength can have an arbitrarily small
amount of energy per photon a photon
with a very short wavelength of
very high frequency will have an
arbitrarily large amount of energy per
photon so on this plot am I doing this
correctly yes look at that on this scale
photons are everywhere depending on the
energy of the photon nevertheless
it might be interesting to plot some
representative interesting photon
energies that you might know about so
let's go to you know one electron volt
ten hundred thousand ten thousand
hundred thousand remember the mass of
the electron is about five hundred
thousand electron volts okay so a little
bit here so maybe here's the mass of the
electron and what you could do is look
up the electromagnetic spectrum that
goes from you know radio waves infrared
visible light ultraviolet x-rays gamma
rays and you could plot it you could
just convert from whatever they give you
the units in you know the wavelength of
the light in angstroms or whatever two
electron volts that's something you can
do at home so I'm not going to do the
whole thing but here's sort of some
typical numbers you know where we are
visible light is roughly here okay
between one and ten electron volts
visible light literally what is visible
to our eyeballs
whereas x-rays are maybe between one and
a hundred thousand electron volts so in
between there's ultraviolet over here
there's infrared etc okay so different
photons have different amounts of energy
but what you see is all of these photons
that you're used to have energies that
are lower than the energy in a single
electron right so an electron and a
positron come together to annihilate in
two photons they will be typically
giving off that doesn't say me that says
mass of the electron they will be
tipping typically giving off a gamma
rays gamma rays are the next highest in
energy after that and these words you
know infrared visible UV x-ray gamma ray
these are not physics words I mean they
may be used by physicists but there's no
physical distinction between these
photons other than their energies other
than their wavelengths okay
they're just photons of different
energies so that's where photons fit on
the plot and of course you can
you could imagine having Planck energy
photons maybe you could have higher than
Plake energy photons who knows we don't
know the laws of physics up there the
Planck scale so we're not sure but the
point is the mass of even an electron
which is sort of the smallest particle
that makes up you is still pretty
massive compared to the photons that
you're looking at it would take a lot of
photons to make up one electron then
there's a related question here's
another fun one that I could have
mentioned once again what about the
quarks where are they because we
mentioned the electron 500,000 electron
volts in energy in mass we mentioned the
proton of the neutron so let me write
that down
mass of the electron is around 5 times
10 to the 5 electron volts mass of the
proton which is about the same of the
mass of the neutron that's about 10 to
the 9 electron volts 1 GeV so that's why
you get GV this is very very common
units in particle physics so what about
the quarks you might think it would be
perfectly natural to think that given
that there are 3 quarks in a proton or
neutron that the mass of a typical quark
is about 1/3 of the mass of the proton
or the neutron we're not going to
explain why just yet we'll get there
pretty soon actually but in fact quarks
are much lighter than protons and
neutrons atleast some quarks are the
quarks that are inside the protons and
neutrons are much lighter than that so
here are the answers there's six quarks
up quarks have masses of about two times
10 to the sixth electron volts whereas
down quarks have masses of around 5
times 10 to the sixth electron volts
I'll tell you others are in a second but
let me just pause to notice here the up
quark and the down quark are only a
little bit heavier than the electron
right an up quark is about four times
the mass of the electron whereas the
down quark is about 10 times the mass of
the electron compared to protons and
neutrons which are about 2,000 times the
mass of the electron so up and down
quarks not that heavy the mass of the
proton and the mass of the neutron which
is where most of your mass
because you're made of atoms and atoms
are made of electrons protons and
neutrons and protons and neutrons have
most of the mass in them most of the
mass in you does not come from those
quarks where it comes from is the
interaction energy of the gluons that
are holding the quarks together in a
complicated way we have to try to
explain that a little bit but it's not
the masses of the up and down quarks
themselves in fact these numbers that
I'm giving you here are a little
problematic because when you talk about
the mass of something you want to
isolate it from everything else and put
it on a scale or you know push it and
use F equals MA or something like that
but as we'll talk about for quarks you
cannot isolate them from everything else
quarks are confined you can have enough
quark inside a proton or neutron but you
can't have one all by itself outside so
in a very real sense the very notion of
the mass of an up quark or a down quark
isn't even really well-defined
as these complications that made me
hesitant to even mention this in the
first place but that's okay
we'll just put it there there's also the
strange quark that's the next heaviest
it's about 10 to the 8th electron volts
there's the charm quark which is about
10 to the 9 the bottom which is about 4
times 10 to the 9 electron volts and of
course the top quark is a big leap
upward it's about 10 to the 11 electron
volts so the charm quark the fourth
heaviest quark is about the mass of a
proton right it's about 1 GeV and the
bottom and top quarks are much heavier
than that as we said as I said in the
previous video when you have these
heavier particles they tend to decay
away it is a process of entropy
increasing because when a heavy particle
decays into lighter ones there are more
lighter particles than there were heavy
ones and therefore there's more stuff
going on and therefore the entropy is
higher someone asked in the question you
know why do we have heavy particles we
don't have every particle there's no top
quarks lying around there's no Higgs
boson lying around particles decay until
they reach decay products that are
stable the electron the proton and the
photon and the
tree nose those are stable particles
they have nowhere to go
of course the proton is still pretty
heavy but it carries what what is called
baryon number it's a conserved quantity
Berrien number is not created or
destroyed in any experiment we've ever
seen and therefore the proton is nowhere
to go it can't decay into anything
lighter because it is the lightest
particle carrying baryon number likewise
electrons and positrons are the lightest
particles carrying electric charge so
they can't decay either neutrinos are
the lightest particles carrying Fermi on
number the total number of fermions etc
so basically that's the story in
particle physics things decay until
they're in the lightest possible state
that has some conserved quantity that
you can't get rid of so it makes you
staple then you're stuck there now
there's a little footnote there because
of course we have things like the helium
nucleus or the iron nucleus or the
carbon nucleus which are stable mixtures
of neutrons and protons and neutron all
by itself out there in the wild can
decay neutron will decay into a proton
and electron and antineutrino
but because of the dynamics of the
strong interactions in the quarks
certain combinations of neutrons and
protons become stable even though
individual and do Tron's by themselves
or not thank goodness because that's the
origin of the periodic table the
elements which is kind of a big deal
okay all this is just to say the quarks
have a wide range of masses and their
masses are not sort of easily
interpretable in any way because the
quarks are stuck inside protons and
neutrons and other strongly interacting
particles okay here's another good
question this is a fun question actually
can you what about if you had hydrogen's
you have proton and electron but you
tried to replace the electron with a
muon instead the muon is just a heavier
particle heavier cousin of the electron
could you make muonic hydrogen it's a
clever question yes you can you can you
can try to make it I'm pretty sure it's
been made they've done all sorts of
crazy things this is a fun thing for
physicists to try to do the important
thing that I wouldn't mentioned is that
the mass of the muon again the
properties of the muon are exactly this
as the properties of the electron except
for its mass so it has charge minus one
just like the electron does it has spin
1/2 there's an anti particle called the
anti muon etc in fact there was a point
of time when the only known elementary
particles were the electron the proton
and the neutron okay these are the first
three that we found and then it was like
literally a few meters away from my
office at Caltech where Carl Anderson by
building a big cloud chamber and looking
at cosmic rays coming from the sky he
discovered the positron the anti
electron and then he discovered the muon
and he discovered the anti muon so the
positron shook people up because anti
particles were not yet accepted they've
been predicted by Dirac but people
didn't know whether to take that
prediction seriously the muon was a
complete surprise no one knew that this
is that's the origin of the famous
comment biii Rabi who said who ordered
that when the muon was discovered but
the point of the anecdote is there was a
little moment of time when Carl Anderson
had discovered the positron the muon and
the anti muon and the only other known
particles were the electron the proton
the neutron so he discovered half of
elementary particles that were known at
the time which is pretty good he
deserved and he got the Nobel Prize ask
yourselves why he discovered the
positron muon and the anti muon before
the antiproton in the antineutron I
won't tell you but you can figure it out
give him things we've already said
anyway the mass of the muon is about 200
times the mass of the electron so the
point is you can make an atom so you
have here's a proton P and then orbiting
around it we'll do our little trick
where we do oops
that's not right we'll do our little
trick where we color in to give the
impression of a wavefunction okay
there you go this is the wavefunction of
the muon now mu - but the point is the
size of the muon academ the equivalent
of the Bohr radius remember the for
radius gives you the size that the
hydrogen atom the ordinary hydrogen
so this is only gonna be one two
hundredth of the Bohr radius it's gonna
be a much more compact atom because the
muon is heavier so when I said you know
ant-man is impossible the point of that
was you can't squeeze things down to
really tiny distances of course the one
way you can is by making them heavier
right you can't keep the mass of the
electron what it is and squeeze it down
below its Compton wavelength but the
muon is heavier so it is smaller so you
can make smaller things out of muons and
people have the problem is the mu1 also
has a lifetime it is not a stable
particle because it can decay into
electrons in fact the muon can decay
into an electron plus two neutrinos a
neutrino and antineutrino and the
lifetime of the muon is about 10 to
minus 6 seconds one millisecond so
that's not good you're not going to get
a lot of stable structures that you are
gonna make out of muons and other things
nevertheless you know physicists are
ambitious sometimes you might know that
we have a Large Hadron Collider in
Geneva before that we have the Tevatron
at Fermilab and we're still thinking
about what the next big Collider will be
so here's an idea yeah so sorry let me
let me back that up there's roughly
speaking to different kinds of particle
colliders that people like to build
hadron colliders and lepton colliders so
hadrons are the protons and neutrons
nuclei that you can make out of them
leptons or electrons basically electrons
and positrons etc hadrons also include
anti protons so Fermi laughs I've had
the Tevatron where they were colliding
protons and antiprotons the SSC sorry
the LHC large hadron collider is just
protons and protons they could do anti
protons but it's hard to make them so
you're gonna get more collisions if you
just make protons hit protons so that's
that's why they did that but there's
also and the reason why you want to do
these hadron colliders these proton
antiproton colliders is because they're
heavier than electrons you can get up to
very high energies so if you're trying
to make the Higgs boson or some other
new particles or whatever you want to
get as much energy into a tiniest face
as possible
heavy particles are good for that
because they have a smaller company
wavelength right but once you've
discovered them you might want to do
very delicate measurements you might
want to figure out exactly what the mass
of the Higgs boson is and exactly all of
its decay products and things like that
that's harder to do at a Hadron Collider
it's not impossible we've done it to
some precision but you can do it more
precisely by colliding electrons or
electrons and positrons together because
they're exactly because they're smaller
and they are as far as we know
fundamental particles I said they're
smaller they're not smaller because
there are fundamental particles because
they're not made up of other things you
know two protons hitting each other you
don't know exactly where the energy is
if it's in this quark or that quark or a
gluon or whatever whereas in an electron
you know exactly where the energy is an
electron and positron for example so
there's a good reason to still build
electron or lepton colliders even though
you can get more energy out of a Hadron
Collider so check it out
you could build a muon Collider and this
is a very active idea people are
thinking about this because muons have
200 times the mass therefore 200 times
the energy of an electron and so you
could get some of the benefit of
smashing protons together and we get
heavy particles and a lot of energy but
also some of the benefit of Smashing
electrons together that there are
fundamental particles you know what all
the energy is doing this is the problem
this is why it's it is so far proven
impractical to do this because the
individual muons decay in a millionth of
a second now you can to a large extent
combat that by just having the muons
move very fast you can use relativity
right if the muons are moving in 99.999%
the speed of light then it seems to us
that they live a lot longer than a
millionth of a second and that's the
trick that's how you can try to get a
muon Collider but even at that look at a
particle accelerator you're not just
keeping two muons or one yuan and one
han time you want and colliding them
together you're generally getting
millions or billions or trillions or
much more than
colliding them together in bunches and
hoping to get some good interesting
collisions out of them so when you get
that many muons together some of them
are going to decay even if they're all
moving very close to the speed of light
and when they decay they give off these
very high-energy electrons but also
neutrinos that can pass right through
matter usually but then they also hit
you so this there was this idea that a
muon Collider with a lot of muons with
you know 10 to the 20 muons in it would
be constantly radiating super
high-energy particles and give rise to
what we called the ring of death
everyone near the collider would be
killed by this high-energy radiation so
that was an engineering problem that
also people not yet overcome as far as I
know I mean maybe they've overcome it
they certainly haven't build a muon
Collider yet okay that was you know that
was a digression but it's a fun by
Gresham um what next just two more
questions I wanted to get to one
question is can there be unknown yet as
yet undiscovered low energy particles
low mass particles the idea of this
question which is a perfectly good
question is look it's hard to make the
Higgs boson hard to make the top quark
hard to make particles even heavier than
that because equals mc-squared you need
energy in a tiny region to make these
new particles but in accion these
hypothetical particles that I mentioned
might have masses of like 10 to the
minus 4 electron volts incredibly
incredibly tiny right that can't be that
hard to make them well so I'm not going
to talk too much about what accion's are
neutrinos by the way also M nu might
have energies around 10 to minus 3 or 10
demised to electron volts so and
neutrinos have the benefit of actually
existing but the point is we discovered
neutrinos why haven't we discovered
accion's if they're so light and easy to
make we might not have discovered them
so they don't exist we're not sure yet
but you don't need just to be able to
make them you'd be able to need to be
able to make enough of them to notice so
the acción in particular is a neutral
particle it has zero electric charge
that's what makes it a good candidate to
be the
ARC matter dark matter is dark dark
means you don't interact with photons
okay if you have a charged dark matter
particle you know look people clever and
the try those things but the simplest
thing in the world the most obvious
guess is the dark matter is electrically
neutral and the accion's don't feel the
weak nuclear force or the strong nuclear
force they feel electromagnetism in a
weird off-kilter indirect way so it is
possible to try to detect them but those
interactions are very very very weak so
typically accion's are one of these
things much like neutrinos where
accion's could be in the room all around
you right now going through your body
and you would never know so the reason
why there could be low mass particles we
haven't yet detected is our ability to
create them depends on their mass but
our ability to know we've created them
to detect them and to see them taking
away energy and momentum depends on
their coupling depends on the strength
of their interaction and so if someone
says they have a new candidate for dark
matter or whatever just some particle
they made up which has a mass less than
the mass of the proton or less than the
mass of the electron for that matter you
can immediately assume that those
particles are very very weakly
interacting they're just hard to know
that they're there the neutrino very
famously was suggested by Wolfgang Pauli
because of I think was beta decay it was
certainly energy conservation issues
beta decay is neutron we already
discussed this neutron goes into proton
plus no distrait plus electron plus as
we now know a electron antineutrino
so if momentum is conserved the neutron
has a momentum the proton has momentum
the electron has momentum and those
proton and neutron momentum you can add
them up and you can ask is the momentum
of the outgoing proton electron equal to
the momentum of the neutron and the
answer was no so obviously there's
another particle taking away some of the
energy some of the momentum but back in
the day like these days you know the
standards are a lot looser now than they
used to be everyone would just say sure
there's a new particle they'll be
instantly what people said back in the
1930s before much
or reluctant to just predict new
particles that had never been observed
so Wolfgang Pauli was the one who said
you know maybe we should take this
energy thing seriously hello people were
saying things like maybe energy is not
conserved right that was on the table as
a possible prediction but instead Polly
said maybe there's a new particle but
he's very embarrassed about it he said
like you know you know don't don't be
mad at me which is which was ironic cuz
everyone knew that polly was the
harshest person on everyone else
whenever they made new predictions for
things but he turned out to be right one
of many things that Pelle he was right
about so there can be low mass particles
as long as they interact weakly the
neutron neutrino rather does interact
very weakly literally through the weak
interactions it took us a while to
detect it directly okay the final set of
questions was what I don't know if it's
a set of questions or not but it had to
do with grand unified theories so I
mentioned grand unified theories because
they might be right you know grand
unified theories we have this situation
right now where electromagnetism
definitely exists figured out
classically by Maxwell in the 19th
century quantum mechanically by I think
was direct who first started down the
road but people like climbing sugar
tomonaga showed it how to make it a
consistent quantum theory then there's
the weak interactions Fermi Enrico Fermi
was the first person to come up with a
sensible theory of the weak interactions
and then it was unified by Weinberg
Salaam and Glasgow into the electroweak
theory there's a complicated story of
why three people get credit for it they
never wrote a paper together but um so
you can I do this what am I doing here
yet but I think Weinberg sort of got it
right let's say that and this is very
successful we'll talk a little bit about
what's going on there but then you also
have the strong interactions so once
this works once this trick works of
unifying the electromagnetic and weak
interactions into electroweak it is
natural to say let's unify strong and
electroweak into grand unified theories
ok so the question I'm not even sure
that's had the question was that sorry
if it people who are
asking this question but it brings up
two issues that were talked about one
issue is that grand unified theories
predict proton decay so I think what it
was was I mentioned proton decay and
people said why would the proton ever
decay I just mentioned a few minutes ago
there's this quantity called baryon
number which is conserved so protons
can't decay
so if protons can decay then that means
a barrier number is not exactly
conserved and this is a feature that was
figured out in the 1970s when Glashow
and howard George I first suggested
grand unification their unifying weak
interactions with the strong
interactions but they don't just unify
the forces they unified them matter as
well they unify the electrons and the
neutrinos which we now call leptons with
the quarks okay so in that basically
there are new forces of nature that are
very very weak because the bosons
carrying them are very very heavy that
can turn an electron or rather a quark
into an electron or vice-versa that can
somehow couple the baryon number
carrying things namely the quarks to
things without baryon number namely
electrons and neutrinos and then you can
go through this is one of the you know
fun interesting anecdotes in the history
of science you could go through in the
1970s and you could say knowing what we
know about grand unification it needs to
have an energy scale something like 10
to the 16 GeV okay 10 to the 25 electron
volts just a little bit below the Planck
scale so number one that's interesting
it's interesting that it's within
spitting distance of the Planck scale
because gravity is where the Planck
scale comes from and gravity it didn't
get mentioned here okay so this was a
and this is a big deal this was one of
the reasons why people took grand
unification so seriously the data you
have in the 1970s is all from
experiments done at some numbers of GeV
right you know the mass of the proton or
ten or a hundred times the mass of the
proton but you can use that data and
this theoretical idea to extrapolate to
a new energy scale
we're grand unification should happen
and the answer is it happens very close
to the Planck scale a factor of 100 is
nothing in this game right so that was
that it just seems like an accident
there seems like a coincidence and maybe
it is because maybe granny fication
isn't right but at the time that was
taken as very suggestive and exactly
because that energy scale is so large
the bosons carrying this new force would
be very very heavy hard to make and
therefore the interactions they mediate
are very rare and therefore protons will
decay very very rarely so in another
coincidence they could figure out how
long it would take proton to decay in
their theory they made a prediction and
beautifully the prediction was I forget
exactly the number but the lifetime for
a proton in gran unification might be
something like 10 to the 35 years
compared to the lifetime of the universe
right now is around 10 to the 10 years
so you might think well that's hopeless
you're never gonna see a decay you have
to wait around 25 10 to the 25 times the
sorry yeah you have to write around 10
to 25 times the age of the universe in
order for this to happen but of course
the answer is you don't wait proton by
proton you don't take one proton and
wait for it decay you take a large
number of protons you take 10 to the
30th or 10 to the 35 or 10 to the 40
protons right and well 10 to the 40 is a
lot but you take a lot of protons and
wait for some of them to decay and it
turned out in the 1970s that this just
about seemed doable with the technology
that they had at the time and so they
built proton decay detectors and they
haven't found it that's the short answer
it's been decades now that that's been
going on and they've not seen the proton
decay so the simplest versions of grand
unification have been ruled out they're
just not right
but of course physicists are very clever
they have assigned their ingenuity to
this problem they've come up with other
versions of grand unification where the
life time is a little bit longer and
therefore you can avoid the current
experiments so then it becomes a
question of how much is it worth it to
you to improve the experiments you can
do the experiment better but
cost money and you know in the 1970s or
80s it was like yeah this is probably
there let's do it and now it's like
maybe it's there we don't know so it's
harder to justify spending that money so
we're not sure yet
that's the sad story the other part of
the grand invocation story is mana poles
so we know that electricity I don't get
too much into this call it's a electric
charge okay electric charge comes in
plus or minus so you have a proton
positively charged you have an electron
negatively charged magnets on the other
hand they have north and south poles but
a magnet always has one of each as a
North Pole and a South Pole and if you
were to cut the magnet in half then this
would become a South Pole and that would
become a North Pole okay you cannot
separate a magnet into one pole at a
time so a magnetic monopole when we say
mono poles we usually but not always
mean magnetic monopoles would be a
particle which was just a North or just
a South magnetic charge all by itself no
evidence of these existing in nature
there's a joke because there's been a
couple of experimental claims that
people have found magnetic monopoles
most people think of those claims were
just false and the joke is no one has
ever claimed to find two magnetic
monopoles people have claimed if I'm one
probably this haven't found them yet and
guess what grand unified theories
predict that magnetic monopoles should
exist for topological reasons we're not
gonna get into that right now but they
also predict they should have this huge
energy this huge mass so they're
impossible to make in particle
accelerators right now this is way these
energies are way way higher than
anything we can make in a particle
accelerator
however the universe is the poor man's
particle accelerator as David Tran like
to say if you didn't do anything weird
if you just had ordinary Big Bang
cosmology at very very early times the
universe was SuperDuper hot and dense
and you could make magnetic monopoles
and they would try to annihilate away
but they were not very successful so
what you could do
calculate if grand unified theories were
correct should you have leftover remnant
magnetic monopoles and the answer is yes
in fact the total energy the total mass
in magnetic monopoles today should be
something like 10 to the 10 times the
actual amount of energy in the universe
the universe should be all magnetic
monopoles if this theory were correct
this is what is called the monopole
problem of grand unified theories and
the monopole problem was what actually
inspired Alan Guth to invent oops
wonderful problem to invent the
inflationary universe scenario inflation
is this idea in cosmology that there was
a period in the very very early universe
with a kind of temporary dark energy
dark energies the stuff that exists
everywhere in space and is pushing the
universe apart and making it accelerate
but imagine that there was dark energy
up with the grand unification scales not
at the wimpy little scale that it's at
today today the energy scale
characteristic of dark energy e lambda
lambda is the cosmological constant the
vacuum is something like 10 to the minus
3 electron volts and what that means is
this 10 electron volts to the fourth
power is the energy density of empty
space today
so during inflation what you want is the
energy scale of inflation is near the
gut scale or near the grand unified
scales that's 10 to the what do we call
it had a 25 electron volts way higher so
the point is if there's a temporary
period of dark energy that makes the
universe accelerate and it will dilute
away all the magnetic monopoles so you
have a huge overabundance of magnetic
monopoles an inflation can get rid of
them and then inflation turns all this
dark energy back into ordinary matter
and radiation but at a lower temperature
the temperature low enough that it won't
make any magnetic monopoles so we can
dilute away all the mono poles now today
we still believe in inflation many of us
think that is a very promising idea to
discuss what happened in the early
universe we don't know we don't know if
we're absolutely sure I would put it it
you know more than 50% chance but not a
lot more if I were forced to bet but the
motivation has changed complete
so Guth's original motivation was this
magnetic monopole problem but in the
back of his head he knew there were
these other problems in cosmology what
we call the horizon and flatness
problems and he showed that inflation
also was a solution to those problems
and we can debate whether or not those
problems are interesting but the point
is they're still there whereas the
monopole problem depends on you really
wanting grand unification to be correct
if granny fication isn't there then
there's no monopole problem there's no
mechanism for making magnetic monopoles
so mono poles are an interesting
theoretical idea they cause good things
and also bad things they could be
problematic if you don't have inflation
but they could be wonderful if you were
able to detect them right you win the
Nobel Prize for doing that so you know
we've we've been introduced here in this
little Q&A to a bunch of particles that
we don't know whether they exist or not
the acción is one magnetic monopole czar
or another that's the fun part about
particle physics you know we haven't
discovered a new surprising particle one
that hadn't been already predicted since
1970s but maybe it'll happen soon
we don't know that's what physics is all
about you gotta wait got to do your
experiments gotta let nature tell you
what's going on